For the past five years, I've been investigating this question of where good ideas come from.
It's the kind of problem I think all of us are intrinsically interested in.
We want to be more creative. We want to come up with better ideas.
We want our organizations to be more innovative.
I've looked at this problem from an environmental perspective.
What are the spaces that have historically led to unusual rates...
...of creativity and innovation?
And what I found in all these systems, there are these recurring patterns...
...that you see again and again...
...that are crucial to creating environments that are unusually innovative.
One pattern I call the "slow hunch": that breakthrough ideas almost never come...
...in a moment of great insight and a sudden stroke of inspiration.
Most important ideas take a long time to evolve and they spend a long time dormant...
...in the background. It isn't until the idea has had two or three years,...
...sometimes ten or twenty years to ensure that it suddenly becomes successful to you...
...and useful to you in a certain way.
And this is partially because good ideas normally come from the collision...
...between smaller hunches so that they form something bigger than themselves.
So you see a lot in the history of innovation, cases of someone who has half of an idea.
There's a great story about the invention of the World Wide Web and Tim Berners-Lee.
This is a project that Berners-Lee worked on for ten years.
But when he started, he didn't have a full vision for this new medium he was going to invent.
He started working on one project as a side project to help him organize his own data.
He scrapped that after a couple of years and then he started working on another thing.
And only after about ten years did the full vision of the World Wide Web come into being.
That is, more often than not, how ideas happen. They need time to incubate.
And they spend a lot of time in this partial hunch form.